[Music]
in not a good idea new submitted by fat
station a family that is too poor to buy
milk needs their baby coffee every day
gives their baby feeds their baby coffee
every day their baby do you see that it
must be a really productive baby cuz
coffee makes me work hard they were
feeding their baby this for eight months
already and that's the only sustenance
that they gave ya it's not even the same
why don't they go soy milk or almond
milk well they live in India and so they
and they're in like a really poor area
how about moms titties I don't know I
don't shit's got nothing they're not the
breasts that one these add cream because
you don't have enough food she cat she's
probably not producing any milk do you
think so like just the baby's like 13
months old and they've been feeding her
coffee for coffee was expensive too but
is there something healthy with the
coffee bean
there's nothing healthy there's no
nutrients in it a little bit of sugar in
there too oh yeah it's weird though
because the baby is like developing at a
normal rate like they're not they don't
look malnourished obviously it's not
healthy for the baby but they're not so
sick and [ __ ] just from just from coffee
yeah so they only make a dollar seventy
four a day
between the two of them and that's how
much it costs them to take care of their
house so the whole family just drinks
coffee all day they're just drinking
coffee they can't I guess give the baby
psych solid foods or anything make a
dollar seventy for a day yeah ungrateful
America shut you could be living like
that but this said that says like I
don't think if the baby solids yeah they
can't because the she's too young at how
many months she's nothing 14 month old
no she's good they're like crushed
apples they haven't been doing that
question fruits baby drinks three
bottles of coffee a day and they say
that she demands her coffee all the time
damn I bet you she wakes up all groggy
and [ __ ] like I can't do anything right
now she's just asking for a bottle like
a normal baby and they're like well she
needs her coffee
the moms like we have no choice they
can't buy milk but she won't go to sleep
unless she has her coffee
I thought she even go to sleep with cars
you should have given her decaf coffee
well they don't ha if they tried to get
milk from like the donation centers like
charities and stuff but I guess they the
charities never gave them the milk so
now they're now that this story has
blown up they're getting like lots of
donations of milk and stuff and the
doctor was like yo you need to stop
doing this it's gonna be really really
bad for your kid later but yeah
sometimes they don't have any work at
all so this like cheap kopi to Brook
coffee made by boiling coffee grounds
with sugar is their go-to replacement
sounds kinda good no no yeah that does
sound kind of good good but you know
like in Asia or like in do you think
Indian coffee or like Turkish coffee
you're like oh yeah I'm like all over
the world this is way stronger than
American cotton like a spice in there
some cinnamon yeah I just think it might
taste a good time oh yeah sorry I wasn't
India it was Indonesia my bad I
remembered porn know what isn't that
where they have those [ __ ] toddlers
that smoke cigarettes I don't know yeah
there's actually remember I think we did
a video on that but there's like a
toddler that loves smoking cigarettes
he's a mean he's like I think I've seen
them that child is in danger
yeah it's not a meme it's robot yeah I
know that poor no dollar 74 today she's
getting titty milk looking look at the
mom's titties there's [ __ ] there's
milk in there all of that look at this
is her face yeah picture I pictured way
worse like a dirt ground
so you even said India I'm like okay
they got when they would like doing
articles ask for a press feed like let
me get $100 yeah y'all come through and
film my baby drinking coffee oh my god
excluding their kids yeah I think that's
what it is and on top of that a dollar
75 a day sounds low to us but if you
convert it to bare money that's what if
that's just a normal it sounds like it's
so pretty poor for them they can't
afford milk rupiah a day cuz when I
think about you can't afford milk I'm
thinking about like those like kids with
the Flies and [ __ ] and then they're like
please give us money so we could build
[ __ ] a well what they do way more
dirt those laminated floors man what the
flying that's way more than a dollar but
yeah they make money extracting copra or
dried coconut flesh and a coconut
plantation which is like why don't they
use the coconut milk yeah or even
coconut juice got so many access to
coconuts give them token at me it's like
milk like a [ __ ] commodity out there
getting there like village maybe they
don't have milk like in abundance they
couldn't buy formula or cow's milk soy
milk agents allergic so that they have
to like give them soy there's got to be
cultures where you don't give milk to
babies though like I don't I think I
don't know if that's aI don't know if
that's a thing though because the women
naturally create the milk no I mean
outside of their titties oh if it's
coming out of the titty then they know
they'd do it for a year because you can
breastfeed for like a really long time
I'm talking about cow's milk like I'm
not sure there's cultures out there that
don't feed cow's milk - yeah I'm sure
you can't replace it with coffee and
sugar oh yeah that's that's for sure but
there's I don't know the mom I was
thinking of them skinny little like same
Schindler's List mom like I was thinking
like fat mom with big titties yeah cuz
she did she he looks robust large in
credit large breasts her titties like
they'll
a gallon of milk I didn't see her
titties you guys are [ __ ] I see your
duties yeah you can see her titties oh
yeah I mean like but that doesn't
necessarily mean they're filled with
milk because like you could have just
excess fat and it doesn't mean that like
it looks like she's been hogging up all
the calories in the house that kids
[ __ ] eating there's no way that kid
only God believe me look at how fat that
cutie this believe oddity central I
tried to Snopes this article but it
didn't come up
that shit's a scam she's eating that
baby's drinking well I don't know yeah
no that baby something's off here dude
yeah the breast yeah and based off the
breast that kids eating good
you got chubby cheeks to the mom like
still never been that they're gonna scam
they need to do a better job well maybe
they're getting fed really good at their
coconut plantation maybe they're eating
the coconut they're eating that well
there cuz cocoa is really fatty so maybe
they're just eating like a lots of
coconuts but then they can't bring it
home cuz their works like no all day on
the job I don't know I'm calling
[ __ ] get a cup and squeeze your
titty I want to find out I squeeze all
the milk out and see how much comes out
if even a drop comes out I'm calling
[ __ ] on this I mean I'm not a titty
expert but they don't I'm a to the
expert okay
do they look milk filled because it no
it doesn't work like that
just big titties doesn't mean you're
lactating unless you have a lot of what
a waste because like wow it's such a
waste because if her titties are that
big it should be able to support and
hold its like it should be yes it's like
a it's like a SUV biology failed her
okay then what does she need to lactate
with those some women just the iron they
aren't able to do it some can
recycling the water out of the fish
comes out right no I doesn't have to
have like optimal vitamin and like
everything not even that some [ __ ] could
just the wiring would be off the wirings
off just suck it clean so the wiring is
straightened out those kiddies are too
big to be lacking of milk too big too
big lacking lactating you know my mother
actually told me one day when I was
child she was like I didn't breastfeed
you because my boobs were too nice
that's what she said yeah so what did
she do just squeeze her Tina in a cup
and it gave it to like I think I just
had coffee yeah well I don't know yeah
my when I was younger and I could be
wrong G oh I assumed that those things
were fully loaded there for her breasts
looked better and she was like well I'm
gonna take advantage of this and go out
and date if you lactate they do get
bigger they stretch out with a leak
you're not what that happens once you're
not locked in anymore they're not as big
but they did get stretch ups and other
floppy titties
so the are they do get National
Geographic titties no matter what but
they get floppy yes like my boobs got so
much softer after I stop softer laughing
like it's not like it's not firm like
droopy ah I have fake tits they didn't
get ribs but they got softer they have
the mommy makeover surgeries where it
like you could get breast augmentation
now they can like pick them up tucks and
like they'd like just make you look not
like you just had a baby so wait let me
just boil it down to this when I have a
child if I want if I want my boobs to
look nice do i breastfeed the child
either way your boobs are gonna get
[ __ ] up or do you care about the child
if you care about the Taipan of
breastfeed a little bit help or your
titties scientifically prove it either
okay because you give formula versus
breast milk doesn't necessarily mean
that it's cuz you breastfeed and then
like they get deflated or you don't
breastfeed and then eventually the milk
goes away and they get deflated so I
like that what scientifically proven
because that all the antibodies and
everything that the mom picks up to
immunities and things like that goes
through the breast so they want the
first like the first like when they're
first born no
like your first cycle of it they do want
them to get that out from that point on
it doesn't like scientifically they
can't prove which one would be better
you would assume the mothers milk would
be better what it does burn calories to
breastfeed it does you're constantly
star doing flapping your arms like well
what's the difference between
breastfeeding and just pumping that [ __ ]
out and in giving the bottle to the baby
there's no difference so then just
having a kid in general it's gonna
produce milk and you're gonna have to
pump it for some people yeah or you just
leave them milk in there well if they're
able to lactate is it bad to leave the
milk in there oh it hurts it's really
painful orge spoiled yeah it's like your
sperm oh but that have to come out to
grey comes out a wet dream is better I
watched your show one time for this lady
had to milk herself because her boobs
hurt is that true it's very true it's
very painful yeah and then like if you
only pump one side versus the other this
one gets deflated and this was just
engorged and you're like in [ __ ] pain
you suck on them for her or not for me
damn [ __ ] breastfeeding part of it
like your nipple gets raw dude dude what
would y'all do the homies if y'all were
hooking up with a lady and like midway
through you were just like oh [ __ ] she's
lactating I start drinking it oh my god
you know it don't tell you that either
and then I'll be like oh wait I'm
leaking too
you gotta suck on it too my milk is
coming out on now because sucking each
other's milk
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]